all right we are now a lot and I'm gonna
start addressing questions and comments
in just a minute I'm going to remind
people that it's important to be civil
not just to me as your host but also to
each other in the streams I usually end
up having to kick a few people out
hopefully that won't be too much of an
issue so yeah that's that's uh I'm going
to turn up the volume just a little bit
here we go
that's hopefully I'll have to say a man
so let me see first question here is
from intellectual jujitsu and it's
asking about Schopenhauer's ethics can I
comment sound keeps going down this is a
problem with Max and sound preferences
sure it's some setting in YouTube let me
see if I can fix this anyway asking
about Schopenhauer's ethics and whether
it's in some way and why the ethics
stoicism yeah and most ethics are in
line with each other in one way or
another but I would say that if you mean
by in line in complete agreement then no
it's not as a matter of fact there's
going to be some issues on which they're
quite out of sync with each other not
least that that Schopenhauer essentially
is following Kant's critique of you
Diamond ISM as being essentially
egoistically self-centered so I you know
I think that that's gonna be a
non-starter right there and show up in
our stoic interconnections I would say
to given the rest of your questions here
it's not derived solely from the
fourfold root strop and our has a whole
work just on morality itself and there's
all sorts of stuff and other sources and
it's not like he you know is developing
a single thing that then
drives everything else like most other
philosophers she's drawing on a lot of
different you could say a lot of other
sources and then rethinking it in his
own way
one thing that where I think you can say
that Schopenhauer's ethics and stoic
ethics are in strong connection with but
also you know Conchi and ethics in some
respects if you look at the metaphysics
of morals or also in some respect
utilitarian ethics if you read it
sympathetically is the the importance of
getting out of our own selfish egoistic
framework and and feeling some sort of
genuine we can call it by a lot of
different names the Stoics talk in terms
of affection or a osis you know we like
to use words like compassion these days
Schopenhauer uses the term sympathy and
a lot of people use the word empathy and
we don't have to get too technical about
this but there is a there is a strong
focus on that in Schopenhauer's moral
philosophy and I think that you can say
that there's overlap there but again
like I said I wouldn't try to say that
they're on exactly the same page as far
as ethics go so let me take the next one
it looks like this this sound thing is
just gonna be at the level that it's at
so if it's a little bit too too low for
you I'm not happy about that but I can
see the input thing going down as I talk
hopefully everyone can hear it alright
so from Abdullah Bach here if someone
wants to start philosophy what do you
recommend I always say start with Plato
and there's there's reasons for that I
think that it's it's nice to read
dialogues and Plato is incredibly
influential on the history of philosophy
so he's somebody who you're going to
encounter at one point or another and I
think that his dialogues are set up in
such
way so is not just to give you you know
like the sort of superficial takes that
intro to philosophy textbook would give
you so and so said this so and so said
this let's think a little bit about it
Plato is like thinking on all cylinders
and you may not agree with what he has
to say at every point but it's
definitely worth seeing what he had to
say
and then thinking through if you
disagree why you disagree with what
usually Socrates is saying at that point
so you know I've I've got some useful
videos on how to do self directed study
on Plato and other philosophers that you
might want to check out alright
Dominus has a bunch of different things
here about the outside agitator thing
I'm gonna remind everybody keep it short
don't try to monopolize the conversation
so I'm just gonna say yeah you're right
there's this trope of outside agitators
has historically been used it doesn't
mean that there aren't outside agitators
that should be called out in protests
right and I don't think the idea of
outside agitators is by itself a racist
anti black myth that's quite that's a
sweeping statement and one that's quite
silly to make that said there you know
it's been used in a variety of ways now
let's actually think about this quite
clearly the notion of outside agitators
as as people coming into protests and
taking them over has indeed been used
against not just blacks but anybody
who's agitating could be labor unions
back when labor unions were actually
quite progressive it could be Hispanics
it could be it could be you know women
aiming for the votes it's not as to be a
purely black thing to begin with but it
is a trope that does occur on the side
of those who want to repress things that
said there are many like in the protests
going on here who are saying hey outside
agitators
like right-wingers or people who just
want to stir up stuff you know
professional anarchists or things like
that get the hell out of here and these
are people within the movement itself so
it's not as if it only has one use and
and we shouldn't pretend that that's the
case
all right Bruce says hello I'm happy to
see Bruce here as well a long-standing
interlocutor let's see what else we've
got so Matt asks how might one for lack
of a better word advertise the benefits
of philosophy how can we draw people in
to learn this kind of stuff or is it
something only certain people gravitate
to so that's a good question
there is no one single stock answer to
that there are plenty of people out
there peddling stock answers which
usually turn out to be something that
they will come in and give talks on or
by their platform or something like that
but there's you know what as with any
other discipline there are many ways to
get into it I mean I think that right
now if given for example the protests
and policing situation if we have
philosophers out there talking about
these issues and saying oh by the way
Aristotle had something to say about
this or all by the way we're so to act
about this dynamic here that might be
useful for bringing people into into
looking at philosophy right and nobody
like crosses the door into philosophy as
if it's a gigantic building and now that
they've crossed the threshold they're
totally in it's you know it's a
continual process and so I think that we
as professionals myself and whoever else
might be watching this or listening to
it we have an obligation to try to do
our best to make philosophy publicly
accessible without watering it down into
stuff that that misleads about what what
philosophers actually think but but it's
not difficult to do you know if you read
not just political philosophy but you
read a lot of stuff in
physics and epistemology and philosophy
of human nature you're like wow this has
all sorts of applications to everyday
life and whether it be you know
extraordinary things like the situation
that we're going through right now
or just you know thinking about how do
you manage your various relationships or
why does the technology that you have
letting you down get you irritated all
of these things are matters that I think
can be gateways for philosophy and you
know how it's so good to go back to your
original question how do we advertise
the benefit of it well partly through
example partly through doing public
writing and podcasts and presentations
and videos and all these other things
and trying to keep reaching out to
mainstream media and you know streaming
services to maybe get some philosophers
on there and not just big-name
philosophers from Oxford but ordinary
people from their community so we have
to do a lot of you know knocking on
doors and getting turned away but I
think also you know the sort of things
that we do in well in Sofia the
nationwide organization and Milwaukee
Sofia the Society of philosophers in
America holding public discussions where
people get to come in and say what they
want to say and we think about it and
talk about it you know all of that I
think now the question is it this is
something only certain people gravitate
to yes but it's not like it's something
that's born in them it's rather do you
have intellectual curiosity well then
you're probably going to gravitate
towards philosophy and so then we should
ask ourselves what are the impediments
to people having that which they
probably had at one point but may have
been drilled out of them all right
another sort of methodological question
from Daniel do I think philosophy has a
place in mandatory educational curricula
how young can people be expected to
learn without the pitfalls outweighing
benefits well if you look at the places
worldwide that actually had philosophy
in the curriculum in a thematic way it's
usually done in high school so you know
France is
is a prime example you know with they're
kind of famous for that but you know you
can also look at other curricula like
some of my videos are used in the
Portuguese national curriculum the ones
on Albert Camus of all things and that's
for tenth and eleventh grade so I think
you know high school is a prime place
but that's not to say that you know you
can't bring it into classes much earlier
on as a matter of fact ideally it would
be and then we would probably I'm not
gonna say we'd have less problems with
education but kids would be further
along here in the United States
unfortunately it's a very hard sell we
have to make a strong case for it and we
also have to offer resources to those
instructors who would like to be able to
do it I've done that sort of work myself
in the past particularly when I was
working at Fayetteville State University
and doing outreach haven't done it too
much here in Milwaukee's but I've been
so busy but it is something that I'd
like to do and I'll mention that there
are organizations out there like one
called Plato it's an acronym and it has
to do with philosophy for children so
there's there's there's people out there
who are specializing in that and I think
you could take a look at them alright
another question about the immediate
situation that we're in with protests
and policing do I know whether the cops
resigning in solidarity after the
punitive action against the two cops by
the way who pushed the old man is true
it sounds to pathological to be true how
could that actually be justified so this
is in New York in in Buffalo which is a
smaller city very close to Canada what
he's referring to there is an incident
where as we've learned further a
long-standing peace worker who actually
you know has a lot of connections with
the nonviolent you know protest and
community building stuff was pushed down
by a police officer cracked his head
open
by the way 75 year old man
and was laying there well the cop
marching asked him okay actually went
check him and was firm and by his is
other hops and stops then lied about it
and said that oh he just felt because
protesters were there you could the
video and see there weren't any around
them that they they pushed it and then
they left him there basically you know
abdicating any any duty that they had to
take care not just a remedy the damage
that they've done but to take care of
their their fellow citizen yes it is it
is true and the other police officers on
this elite team did resign and they
resign not because we're sick of police
brutality a benign because they didn't
want their fellow at least lost for
being disciplined for and this is part
of the problem police not held
accountable for the actions that they
engage in and the police union supported
them and even the mayor came in and and
lied the national stage about who the
guy was and about what was going on so
what we've got here is a lot of
despicable lie and a lot of cover-up and
this is exactly what the protests are
about and and it's interesting the
dynamic is that you know protesters are
angry about a long-standing problem with
police you know
wrongful evil unjust actions getting
being you know not not getting any sort
of attention or discipline I mean think
about what it would be like if we didn't
have cameras they lie all the time then
I mean they already lie with cameras on
them so the protests are about that and
what's the answer to the protests do
more of that on the part of the cops I
mean they're just showing that the
protests are are justified right so now
how could the police actions be
justified they cannot be justified there
there is I mean any ethical stance that
would say that these police actions are
justified is an inherently wrong unjust
and likely evil ethical stance it's and
it's an Archon and that it's can so much
- of people
to get there but that's that's the case
can hear a crowd outside right now it
sounds like well the protest is marching
past our our place all right Isaac asks
what do you think is an ethical phosphor
whose idea or not taught or discussed
enough that pretty much all of them know
we we should have some of the key ideas
in ethics being part of the curriculum
everywhere and they should be part of
you go back to the police issue they
should be part of police training and
not just like a little seminar that you
sit through annual training and training
retrain you know being a peace officer
should be a job that is not difficult
because you have to do with criminals
and you deal with the brass hey but it
should be difficult because you can
actually do the morally difficult things
and you need and we could say the same
thing about about you know people who
are in medicine and we can say the same
thing about business people so you know
there isn't a single philosopher who I
think whose works need to be taught more
I think we need to teach a lot of it
more
alright Gustavo asks do I read in other
languages yes to some degree I remember
seeing in money or videos some
addictions and languages other than
English give it a nice about reading a
second language I have an entire video
about it's called titled languages I use
in my work so you might want to check
that out
I read French you know very easily
German I got to work in a bit more
depending on who's writing it too you
know some people are much fake there's
Hegel never you need to read it's not a
great writer quite frankly you know I
read Greek and Latin and I can also
puzzle out academic Italian and
Portuguese in Spanish but I can't like
actually read stuff per se in those
those languages but I don't you know I
don't do it all that often do I have
advice about reading in a second
language you know I mean you're doing
you're effectively translating for
yourself right so and it gets better the
more that you do I just like any other
and it so that set of skills
all right Chris Meyer thoughts on Derek
Parfit not somebody I'm particularly
interested in and I've never really
given much attention to them so I
quickly get my thoughts on Derek Parfit
Bradford asked can i name any philosophy
or philosopher that would I just jumped
here would here we go or it could be
construed to support what the Trump
government is doing is it as clear as
saying something like a political
ideology
so let's contrast here what the dump and
ministration is doing and then we've got
all the different police departments and
different cities and sheriff's
departments and then we have individual
people you know doing things as well are
there are there any philosophy these are
flusters who would back up what they're
doing sure yeah
and though that's probably more of a
problem with their those philosophers
right I mean I think Thomas Hobbes other
than he would consider Trump to be a
particularly weak and despicable
individual from a psychological
perspective Hobbes would still say well
you know sovereign power doesn't I mean
that's part of Hobbes as shtick is it
doesn't matter how you know poorly
informed or gross in terms of you know
moral depravity a person is if they're
the sovereign you're kind of stuck with
them right I know we could talk about
the Chinese legalists who rightly were
deposed you know the Qin Dynasty that
later
you know leads for the Han Dynasty some
of those ideas are still incorporated
into Han practices and I you know I
think you can find all sorts of people I
mean if you have the right read of
Machiavelli's The Prince you can somehow
justify what what Trump is doing I mean
if you have the right read of the prince
he would actually be the kind of person
who has violated all sorts of
Machiavellian principles he's a great
example of the rich person or the
powerful who the prince would actually
reign in because the you know they're
always trying to screw with the weaker
and the poor but it's oh yeah you can
you can find justifications in some
philosophies I mean there's almost
nothing that you can't find some beating
somebody defending at one point or
another all right Ron Payne what can
Christians do in their thinking to make
it clear that they have a unique witness
to the world that they shouldn't be
co-opted by either the political right
nor the political left I mean I don't
think that Christians actually do have a
unique witness to the world that's
that's probably going a little bit far
as a matter of fact the first thing that
a Christian should do if they want to
make a witness to the world is figure
out whether they're really a Christian
or not or whether they're one of the
people that you know by the way that
they act and the things that they say
and the people who they leave in the
lurch would when they meet with Christ
you know the famous parable Christ would
say yeah I don't know you buddy I know
that guy over there who fed the hungry
and you know called the naked visited
the prisoners I don't know you so I mean
I think that's probably the first thing
that one needs to do before worrying
about being co-opted and you know in
point of fact no matter what position
you and you're gonna get co-opted get
used to it you know the question is what
are you gonna do in relation to that so
you know you try to follow the gospel
right that's that's the center so all
right Chris what are your thoughts of
the calls to defund police does there
need to be clarification on what this
means good question yeah yeah we
definitely need clarification because
defund could mean like we cut off money
altogether to the police which is very
impractical I mean who are you actually
gonna get to do that the City Council
they're not gonna go for that I mean
there's talk
the Minneapolis City Council member who
wants to do that but it's not a it's not
a real proposal that's gonna get through
mayor's that's that's a hard sell so if
you mean like completely cut off all
funding for police that's that's
probably a no-no starter but people want
to yell for that that's that's fine let
them for a while and then afterwards let
the you know people who are a bit a bit
more level-headed coming in and say okay
what can we actually do and what could
we actually we could reduce police
funding right we could make earmarks and
we could say we'll fund you
but you can't spend it on this and you
can't spend it on this and you can't
spend it on this or we tie things
together like we say okay you want to
have tear gas you can have tear gas and
you have to spend an equal amount of
money on these programs over here or we
can make things contingent we can say
listen until your numbers come down for
this and this and this you're not
getting paid and another thing that we
can really do so you know this is not
defunding per se but we really need to
get rid of qualified immunity
protecting police officers from you know
being held accountable for their abuses
when places are getting sued in civil
court for abuses of police power the
police officer who is involved in the
abuse should pay restitution and that
should mean losing losing any pension
that they have and probably the
forfeiture of the assets that they they
have I would even go so far as to say
you know if we're gonna think this out
first freeze their assets then allow
their spouse to divorce them and let the
money go with the spouse and then
whatever is left over that police
officer loses that and they can live in
a little shitty apartment in the very
areas that they thought they were too
good to police
you know defunding could mean a lot of
different things but we need to see some
real accountability and that's I think
what defunding if it's going to be
workable has to be about some all right
Artie Whitby do I think the similarities
between stoicism and Buddhism are pure
coincidence or do I think that they
exchanged ideas I think that the answer
is neither I think that what we have in
the case of the similarities between
stoicism and Buddhism are ideas that are
being worked out in similar ways in
different places without connections but
then we can afterwards see these
similarities between them I don't think
that we need to you know account as
people so often want to do for
similarities by saying one must have
gotten this from from the other and I
think that when we focus on the
similarities we also have to be very
clear about what the dissimilarities are
oftentimes surface-level similarities
when we look at them more closely don't
turn out to be quite so similar I do I
will say something here this is gonna be
a little bit of a rant big surprise to
all of you right that I'm doing anything
like a rant so I think that there's a
lot of people who seem to be very
invested in wanting to see a connection
between Buddhism and stoicism that that
just isn't there it you know
historically and so there's a lot of
reading in and this is a sort of a
broader problem in doing bad history of
ideas there's a lot of reading in could
be possibly may be you know sort of
stuff rather than focusing on what's
what's actually you know verifiable
historically so I think that's that's a
key problem scrolling down looks like I
got a clean up a bit of this stuff so
there's a lot of good questions here all
right let me scroll back up and see what
we've we've got
to do a lot of questions
alright so in Sarah how highly do I
regard anarchism I don't take it that
seriously I think that it you know there
there's there's a lot of authors who
have good things to say I can't see
adopting anarchism as a general program
or principle myself you know I know
that's probably about all I have to say
about it okay Dimitri how do we get out
of the problem of indexical x' and an
omniscient God for example God can't
know the statement I am Greg because
that would mean they're not God I don't
see that as a real problem myself that's
that seems to me a real pseudo problem
so all right Louise Gerardo Rojas
salario I want to start reading
Kierkegaard can you give me advice yeah
and this advice would go for a lot of
philosophers as you jump into somebody
who's got you know complex and
convoluted thoughts particularly
somebody who writes in a polemical way
and from multiple points of view
don't try to like get Kierkegaard down
and then like be able to say oh this is
exactly what he's saying because he's an
ironic author he will often then a
little bit afterwards disappoint or
frustrate you by adopting a perspective
that that is not the one that you had
with Kierkegaard you you have to
consider that the work is not meant to
be one big systematic whole the way it
would be for somebody like hunch right
and you know it's it's it's interesting
when you're reading Kierkegaard you're
gonna see a lot of references to other
thinkers not just Hegel and not just
Socrates of course we were sort of the
two representatives of the ethical he
references Descartes he references
Pascal II references all these Church
Fathers and it could be good too
know a little bit about what those
people are saying you know that's
probably enough about about Kierkegaard
training my mind are you a night of
faith no I am that Marcus says I
recently read GK Chesterton's orthodoxy
have you read it and what do you think
of his comments on insanity I I'm a big
fan of Chesterton I I like him quite a
bit and so what are his remarks on
insanity the insane person at least
certain kinds of insane person he's not
trying to categorize insanity per se and
explain the general you know theory of
all of all the neuroses and psychoses or
as we now call them today disorders he's
just saying that a lot of crazy people
and a lot of people who aren't in the
lunatic asylum have a world that is too
small
and I think you could say this applies
to a lot of people in terms of their
political ideology and their you know
their place in what they view is the
culture of course if you can't take take
account of things that other people seem
to think are reasonable that are staring
you in the face that's because you have
a world that's too small and you're
gonna keep doing some sort of you know
repetition of your particular stance and
you know you can't it's very difficult
to see from that perspective that you're
actually the nutter
you know so here in America for example
the people who have fetishized parts of
the Constitution into you know their
freedoms my liberties you know we like
to joke nowadays and don't give a [ __ ]
about the common good or how what
they're doing affects other people
they're they're kind of insane from a
Chester Tony end point of view and I
think he if you were today if you're
here today I think he would be calling
them out by the way I'll say this too so
Chesterton is of course a Roman Catholic
he was a convert and he mostly gets read
by by you know conservative to
the middle-of-the-road Catholics but if
he were around today he would probably
call out most of the conservative
Catholics that are out there who you
know are focused primarily just on
abortion and then what the Republicans
do anything that they want in the name
of you know getting judges in there and
ignore all the cruelty and you know
eventually sort of swallow the kool-aid
Paul Ryan being being a prime example
from my own State
I think if Chesterton were around he'd
be skewing those people just as much as
the you know the nutters on the left so
all right TJ bonnet have you read about
virtue ethics and Confucianism do you
think virtue ethics can be usefully
applied in non-western context so the
first time that I encountered
Confucianism would have been in high
school and then I've taught it route you
know routinely in my world religion
classes and in upper level classes on
Eastern philosophy and religion so yeah
I'm kind of familiar with Confucianism
don't read classical Chinese so I you
know I'm less comfortable opining on
exactly what a passage says then I would
be if I was doing something coming from
Latin or Greek but yeah I know a little
bit about Confucianism and there's a lot
of debate back and forth in the
scholarship is it a virtue ethics is it
more of a ontological it's probably you
know sort of like stoicism kind of a mix
of the two and there's a vast Confucian
literature as well you know so it's not
just reading the Analects or the amongst
ax you know there's also all this other
stuff going down to the the present so
do I think virtue ethics can be usefully
applied in non-western context I think
it has been usefully applied in
non-western context for several
millennia I think that virtue ethics can
be found in a lot of places it's it's
less of a question of whether it's it's
there and it's more a question of how is
it formulated and what other elements
are there in it and how sophisticated is
is
the virtue ethics that we're talking
about and with Confucianism it's pretty
sophisticated you know so yeah all right
Joey hey Greg are you an atheist is
because I wonder what your position on
the origins of morality some arguments
lead to Neil ISM in this way or
conscient hypothetical propositions so
you're probably referencing though like
if you take God out of the picture there
can't be any morality nonsense [ __ ]
that atheists and and foolish Christians
often debate about which is like you
know it's like listening to toddler
squabbling and then going you know you
leave that and you like look through the
past moral tradition of both theist and
atheist philosophers who don't buy into
any that sort of nonsense no I'm not an
atheist but it wouldn't really make all
that much difference to how I teach
things if I was because if I was an
atheist I wouldn't be a sort of Crusader
you know religion is all bad kind of a
theist I'd be like some of my friends
who are atheists who are like well you
know there's this this thing I don't
like over here but this thing over here
they've actually got something on us so
all right mr. Dharam podgy do you have
to be good at math to understand
analytic philosophy no you don't really
because they're not using math they're
using mathematical notation and it's too
simple the language and it's not
actually even mathematical notations
logical notation so I don't I don't
think you need to be particularly good
at math William Zen any thoughts on how
to measure progress and a self-directed
study of philosophy that's a good
question I I should probably do a video
about that so you can certainly use the
benchmark of like well how much did I
understand before and how much do I
understand now but that's always gonna
that's not a great measure because
you're always gonna be saying well [ __ ]
I understand a lot more now than I did
before because I've been studying right
so maybe you do it at certain points
right and you say okay how much do I
understand now
compared to last month how much better
do I understand things and you know it
understanding is not just at one level
there's going to be various levels where
like now you see for example let's say
we take can't so you you've studied the
groundwork you use the resources that
are out there you're reading it through
multiple times you're trying to think
about how you would apply it and that's
good and then you actually read the
metaphysics of morals because the
groundwork is the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals right so you read
the actual metaphysics of morals and
then you're you're you know you're
seeing the connections between the two
well that's another kind of
understanding so but that is actually a
really great question that's something I
should put more thought into and do a
video on that's something I probably
need to like tap into the expertise of
some on my peers as well you know who
are doing similar stuff so all right
chunky pop can you briefly explain
Hegel's dialectic and its differences
from Marx materialist dialectic or more
specifically how would you put dialectic
thinking for the layman so I wouldn't
dialectic is complicated does any
schematic approach to it is going to be
wrong it's not going to actually
correspond to what Hegel or even Marx is
doing with it can I briefly explain it
no I can't briefly explain it it's an
Hegel can't briefly explain it either
you know all those sort of like teach
yourself this or Hegel in 90 minutes
those purport to do that but they're all
off base I mean there's a reason why
it's it's complex all right
you know so factotum says in germany
there's a law preventing members of
groups radically opposed to the
Constitution to work for the government
this prevents members of neo-nazi groups
to become policemen but a lot like this
be possible in the US and do you think
it would help I don't think you'd ever
get a law like
passed not not in our divided political
system and then once you did the actual
application and an interpretation of it
would be tied up forever and it wouldn't
really achieve much because I mean look
at all of our big disagreements about
what the Constitution actually means we
have we have these people who think that
the Second Amendment means that they get
to walk around these you know these big
fat out-of-shape neckbeard you know
protesters with all sorts of tricked-out
guns and stuff some of them are actually
carrying fake guns I saw an idiot down
in North Carolina carrying a painted
wood replica of a 50 caliber machine gun
something that when I was in the Army it
took four of us to carry around you know
so there's that sort of like level of
[ __ ] re and then there's you know
there's people who are like well no the
Second Amendment only means being in a
well-regulated militia and they're you
know they're unless it's called a
militia you know in these sort of
nitpicky bullshitters and then there's a
lot of us in the middle of her like [ __ ]
I just don't want to get shot you know
and I don't want people who I like and
care about to get shot or feel scared
because these [ __ ] want to carry
around guns so we don't have the sort of
Constitution and we don't have the sort
of civil society that would actually
make a law like that useful it's cool
that that in Germany that can keep the
neo-nazis out of the police force I'd
love if we can keep them out of the
police force you know I'd love if we
could keep all the racists not only out
of the police forces but I think you
know kick him out of the military as
well the Border Patrol I mean the Border
Patrol is just rife with that sort of
stuff
Customs and Border Patrol but it's
that's not going to happen instead we're
gonna have to work for all sorts of
little incremental changes we're gonna
have to keep pushing and pushing and
pushing you know I keep bringing up this
this phrase consistent profess
consistent pressure relentlessly applied
that's what it's going to take to
produce important changes all right Owen
the American Psychological Association
is deemed
traditional masculinity as pathological
stoicism was one of the negative
characteristics named any thoughts on
these strange developments yeah we
talked about this months and months and
months ago when it came out what they're
calling stoicism is not stoicism case
ended I mean there's literature out
there responding to this so not sure why
that's why that's coming up as an issue
now mark says who do you believe is a
strongest pragmatist philosopher I'm
very much interested in this line of
thought so strongest you know it depends
on what you mean like is able to address
things the most has the most followers
clearly John Dewey has had the greatest
influence as a pragmatist although he
calls what he's doing instrumental ISM
but I don't like doing
I actually don't even really like Dewey
ins that much there's a few I would say
there's a few good ones like my friend
Phillip Dean but when people start
talking about Dewey usually my eyes
glaze over and I actually worked at the
Center for Dewey studies for a semester
as an archivist system I'm really
partial to William James I you know so
let's talk a little bit of background
stuff right when we're talking about
pragmatism classical American pragmatism
the big names are Charles Sanders purse
Josiah Royce who's sometimes you know
looked at as a bit of a you know
renegade and more of an idealist than a
pragmatist but he's a pragmatist William
James of course John Dewey and then
there's a whole bunch of other people
sort of in the background as well
leading all the way down to Richard
Rorty and someone people indicate John
Locke's you know and I gotta say I who I
like Royce and purse a lot and if you
were to ask me ten years ago I was at
Royce as the one who I like the most but
I've really come around to William James
I do like him quite a lot so
yeah here's an interesting question what
philosopher has made you laugh the most
lev chest off hands down he is a funny
guy
he's an existentialist who not too many
people read important enough to get
named by Camus who is one of the people
that who use targeting in the myth of
sisyphus but unfortunately chef stuff
who is a emigres Russian Jewish author
who then settled in Paris after the
Revolution only had one main student and
he died in the concentration camps
his name was fondant and chefs toffs
works are incredibly funny and I
actually like him quite a bit you know I
think most people encountered him
through Athens and Jerusalem which is
probably one of the least funny of his
works but his early stuff is is really
on point when it when it comes to that
so um all right um then Thomas oh well
let me take this and then I'll come back
to Jada's question can I give any tips
on how to learn Latin in a self-directed
way as a matter of fact I'm going to get
up for a second and get something that
is what I used so you can get yourself a
wheel lock or any of those teach
yourself Latin things but sooner or
later you want the Allen in green Oh
grammar right because you you actually
do want to learn how the language is
structured and what's cool about this is
it's you know it's very comprehensive
that gives lots and lots of great
examples that you can work your way
through and it's it's um the people who
are interested in this well I can see
the dust coming off of it
the people who develop that at the time
were doing comparative indo-european
linguistics so if you know German or you
know
odds are you don't Sanskrit or you know
ancient Greek there's all sorts of good
comparative stuff in there now is that
the way everybody should learn Latin I
don't think so because different people
learn in different ways and it's often
quite tough to you know to learn the
same way that other people do I think
actually I'm looking at the thing I'm
gonna move things a little bit right now
and get out of this hot Sun move my
chair then sitting in play don't bump my
coffee that's always a tragedy ah there
we go that's much nicer much cooler and
it's a good thing you asked me that
question prompted me to get up and take
care of stuff alright let's let's look
at the next one or rather jump back up
Jada
do you think we have an obligation to
post on social media our thoughts on the
recent happenings around the country
people seem to have this expectation
from others that's a great question so I
would say is an ordinary person no I
don't think there's a moral obligation
to post anything and I think the people
who are pressuring other people to you
know to do so or to post things in this
way or else you don't support you know
this or that I think that they're
they're not just wrongheaded about that
but I think that's the sort of thing
that tends to confirms people people's
worries and stereotypes about activists
you know I can tell you this that for me
you know I've been seeing the stuff
that's been going on for for quite a
while and I do post about other justice
issue
you know things from essentially from a
virtue ethics perspective and I've been
doing so for quite a while but this this
incident and and the responses that
people have and seeing the brutality of
the police across the nation and seeing
our you know not just lack of leadership
a malignant leadership coming from
Whitehouse and you know the Department
of Justice and and the well we can go on
and on for me that's turned a point I I
feel that I in the past I might have not
posted something and now I'm gonna post
it and you know lose some supporters and
fans through doing so but [ __ ] them
you can hear the protests outside right
now that's you know it's tough [ __ ] if
people don't like it if they if they are
too thin-skinned or if they want to like
justify the police stuff get them off my
stuff they don't have to be I don't have
to give them a place in my social media
just because I have a Facebook page
doesn't mean doesn't mean that anybody
gets to post anything that they want
there it's more like my front porch so
if you were sitting on my front porch
and you wanted to like say that those
you know officers pushing the 75 year
old man over well there's two sides to
the story I'd say get the [ __ ] off my
porch
you know don't come back and so I think
you know there's a lot of things here
that that we can do and do we have a
again do we have a moral obligation to
post I don't think so
but if we want to take that on it's sort
of this is what we would call a super or
OGG Ettore duty right all right let me
scroll down Chris Christian Hoffman says
thanks for my recent pop up about the
current events have I heard her read
anything recently on the topic which has
been really thought-provoking for myself
on these events I wouldn't say that
there's any one single thing that I've
heard her read that has been like you
know above all the rest it's been
there's a lot of stuff out there
happening and and I think one of the
things that's that's so important right
now is to actually stare the the
brutality in the face there's a long
thread out there that you can find on
Twitter that has incident after incident
after incident of police attacking
protesters and you know people get what
happened before the video you know watch
the video and then ask yourself whether
anything that
happened before that video would justify
that use of force in that that
circumstance and if it would well then I
think we would part ways right until of
course you get caught up in that and and
see somebody using that sort of force on
you or people you care about but I think
for most of us those sorts of things are
really catalyzing and I'm really
grateful that we have my cell phones
over there that we have these cell
phones that can record these things
because otherwise people again would be
lying about what's what's been happening
[Music]
alright Totten what philosophers do you
like on how to overcome or deal with
Neil ISM well Nietzsche
Nietzsche thinks niall ism is one of the
big problems of our time I don't want to
say that we necessarily have to endorse
everything that he said but he's got
some good advice and some good thing
about Oh Albert Camus
might be a bit more on point you know we
could go the existentialist in general
are struggling with lineal ISM in the
face none of them actually are me Alice
they see it as a real problem that we
have to address so I would say that's
that's one of the resources to go to
autodidact learner any tips on how to
read on the academics by Cicero yeah so
remember that what what Cicero is doing
is his usual let's place ideas in and
deep dialogue with each other it's kind
of cool that we actually have on the
academics because otherwise we wouldn't
know that much about the epistemology of
the these ancient schools because
unfortunately so many texts have been
lost so I would say you know the other
thing I would keep in mind too is you
can you can read it in continuity with
his other works where he's bringing in
representatives of the Stoics and the
Epicureans and the academic skeptics and
you know Aristotelians and people
all right Samuel do you think there's
objective moral truth if yes how if no
why I'm not sure how you what how would
mean do I think there's objective moral
truth sure although it kind of depends
on what you mean by objective doesn't it
so you know and then how I mean there
are moral truths out there we can
discover them sometimes we have to like
refine them but we've been doing that
for now 2,500 years this doesn't seem
like it really tricky matter you know so
I I'm often kind of puzzled about people
who who get you know where this is like
their main focus I don't I don't really
know that that much what to say to them
all right I just lost the thread it
bounced a little bit oh okay
so here's an interesting one what are my
thoughts on Ray Romano varam so that's
referring to the encyclical by leo xiii
which has to do with catholic social
teachings and specifically about the
economy i think it's a good document i
think there's a lot of stuff in there
that's quite cool you know there's
there's a f reaffirmation essentially
because this isn't thomas aquinas that
there there is no such thing as an
absolute right to private property
there's an affirmation of the right to
organize and the need to you know make
justice the central thing in there i
think that would actually be very
scathing if the you know leo xiii were
to look at contemporary worker labor
unions today because there's a lot of
problems and abuses but you know it's
it's it's an integral part of catholic
social teachings i think it was it was
well needed at the time and i think that
very few Catholics actually read it
especially those who would
probably benefit from it and I think
that non-catholic should read it too
because then you can get to see just
like you know we don't say oh I'm not a
confucius so I'm not gonna read you know
the Analects you should read it you know
it's a good document um let's see here
ml pianist in my work what's the most
useful concept I found in lakhan's work
that's a good question so I would say
it's the idea that psychotherapy is not
taking as its goal curing a person or
restoring them to some previous you know
integrated self but rather it's a way of
making sense out of how how screwed up
we are and getting ourselves to the
point and you see this like an in third
wave therapy now like acceptance some
commitments the commitment therapy right
they're there they've latched onto
something that Lacan realized a long
time ago it's about figuring out how to
be okay with the things about you that
are [ __ ] up that you know you're not
able to really make progress on either
because you've reached the limit on that
or you you know there's just nothing you
can do like I mean I can I I couldn't
like try to work out my relationship
with my long dead father but you know he
can't talk back to me I so I can write
them all the letters I want but sooner
or later the narrative is kind of stuck
and and how to get okay with that
that is that is what Lacan thought
psychotherapy and large part was aiming
it and you can see this very much in his
seminar on the ethics of psychoanalysis
so all right bhf Hegel's negation does
it mean that i should rob a bank in
order to become since robbing a bank is
against my being no that's not what
Hegel's stuff says it also all right to
do let me scroll down
Bruno Dahle Mullin is there anything you
hate or dislike about philosophy or a
particular philosopher yeah I I dislike
the fact that our profession has become
largely people who are cool with just
doing their thing and not engaging in
public outreach and who you know there
the philosophy supposed to be in a
certain way egalitarian but also Mara
Craddock and it's neither of those and I
think there's a lot of people who are
very cool with that so I would say
that's that's the thing that I dislike
about my profession here's a tough
question from Maxwell Thomson Kurtz what
to do if your dad is all right
misogynist implicitly racist and just
all-around selfish well I'm sorry that
that's the case there's not a there's
not a hell of a lot that you can do with
a parent or colleague or friend who who
has those dispositions by itself I think
the best thing that you can do I mean if
you if you're still like in conversation
you can have conversation you can like
press your points and and hope for the
best
but they may lash out at you quite a bit
you know like my own dad who's a retired
deputy police chief in a regular Police
Department and when I say my own dad I
mean my bio dad not my dad adopted dad
and who's been a Park District police
chief for quite a while and who is
actually a very thoughtful man
you know like on the drug issues he's
been able to call out his fellow cops
and say really the position you're
taking is quite stupid you know but when
it comes to some of the other things
like the protests and gun rights and
stuff like that Easy's much more on the
right you know I'll tell them as does my
my half-brother well I think you're
wrong on that and then we kind of leave
it at that we don't we don't push back
and forth
you know and he said well don't you have
a duty to like convince people no I
don't because I actually want to
preserve that relationship and generally
he's not a mattress about that but if
you're if you have somebody who is
genuinely obnoxious about that you might
have to say I I'm not going to have this
relationship with you and it's
unfortunate because they're essentially
forcing that on you and the way it
typically goes in these sorts of
dynamics is they will present it as
you're the one who's making things
difficult and so I really feel for you
I'm having that that sort of thing to
deal with all right let's see here
tripping Adrian is asked a question that
a lot of people have asked before what's
my opinion on Carl Jung's work I'm not a
big I don't buy into most of his stuff I
like reading young because he's a good
writer but I don't buy the archetype
stuff and I you know I just and talking
with young'uns people who are like
followers of his stuff I don't usually
get much out of that Rubicon why don't
they talk about the cops getting killed
by rioters like David Doran shouldn't
everyone be accountable for their
actions they do talk about it I mean
they don't talk about it enough for you
because that's where your focus is
clearly and everybody else who's always
like well what about the police what
about them they're innocent victims you
know if you're a cop you're taking money
to be out there policing and if you get
killed by a rioter that's part of the
the what goes with it sort of like being
a soldier you know we are talking about
them we're doing it right now and
there's plenty of [ __ ] out there about
them you know and go in the right-wing
media that's all they talk about
non-stop you know soon as when you give
as much attention to that as you do to
each one of the people who's been at
attacked by police then I'll take you
seriously but
till then you know that's just one of
those those sort of things shouldn't
everyone be accountable for their
actions
yeah so you hold everybody accountable
for their actions including the cops and
then and then worry about you know no
more you know press coverage for cops
being killed by rioters all right
Edmund Burke who do you like more
Jesuits or Dominicans neither the order
I like the best is the Benedictus all
right I'm skipping over people have
already asked quite a few questions
nefarious when police are opening fire
against peaceful protesters albeit with
gas or rubber bullets would it be wrong
for protesters to respond with an
aggressive defense no it would not be
wrong because police are in at that
point the aggressors now we should be
really clear teargas is quite often
going to not just be a non-lethal thing
it can it can kill people depending on
what the circumstances are rubber
bullets are you know not always rubber
and they're knocking out people's eyes
maiming them for life right being aimed
deliberately at vulnerable spots on
people so you know I don't I think if
the when the cops go over the line and
attack crowds and attack people who are
not actually rioting or looting or
something like that or attacking the
cops directly with you know physical
force that's really going to affect them
throwing a water bottle and then you
know hitting somebody the club that's a
real escalation there when the cops go
over the line they become aggressors and
then they should be judged by it you
know the actions against them should be
judged as we would any other self
defense against a criminal so all right
Jin Stampede asks what's my view on the
Joe Rogan podcast deal how can someone
like him clearly lacking any actual most
issues that's such a famous and highly
rated
that's a good question I don't know I
think part of the fact the people who I
know who like to watch his show they say
that they like his willingness to talk
with people so I think that's that's a
big part of it I don't actually
understand the attraction of Joe Rogan
myself but you're right it is certainly
a phenomenon and I know quite a few
people who do enjoy watching his show I
don't watch it you know in Perkins and I
the time people are recommending videos
and things to me all the time I'm not
I'm not spending you know more than just
a few minutes quite often if somebody
sends me something to click on it
because I get I got stuff to do
right like this for example all right
Floyd Cotter where do all philosophical
models break down what's the girdles
incompleteness theorem bail test and
philosophy so I mean the granola
incompleteness theorem has to do with
form Eliza ballista might and I'm
looking over there because my girdle
Eschenbach book is this on the shelf
over there we spent an entire semester
working through that in a seminar
mathematics seminar when I was an
undergraduate and the girdle is
incompleteness theorem applies to
mathematics in any other form Eliza ball
system it shows that it either has to be
incomplete or inconsistent so does that
really affect like ordinary life not
really does it affect all philosophical
models I don't think so because you
don't have to have a philosophical model
that aims at being mathematize well
Hegel system is a great example you know
in there I I do think that there are
ultimately inconsistencies in it but you
know and it does aim to be comprehensive
which definitely isn't but I don't think
it breaks down because that you know I
think oftentimes what we see and this is
what you know deconstruction kind of
turned into their shtick when we think
through a philosophic
whole perspective or model or system and
turn it on itself often inconsistencies
or gaps do emerge but that's often quite
far down the line so all right Diogenes
asks is the ethics of psychoanalysis the
best introduction of Lacan I don't know
that there is a best introduction to
Lacan
I think that that's a good way to go at
it I think the seminars are easier to
read in general than the akr look has
difficult no matter what
in part because and and part of the
blame is his he was a little bit what we
call precious right in French press use
which means kind of full of himself and
showing off and all that and he did that
in part to like stick it to the
psychoanalytic establishment which
treated him quite bad in many respects
but he also did it because he was kind
of a show-off you know once you like
peel that stuff away and you're like
look how what the hell are you talking
about which is you know some
interpretation that you have to do on
your part you know what he has to say is
actually quite interesting all right
Sean part any opinion on Dziedzic at all
and the others take on Hagel as being a
philosopher of contradiction and not the
synthesis this whole idea there being a
failed absolute or contradiction that
can't be overcome
I'm not really that interested in that I
mean that's still just doing kind of
like grand philosophy on a grand scale
with big names and big ideas and saying
what everything's all about I'm
interested in Hegel more for like does
it you know can we use this dynamic
what's he saying here you know I already
don't buy Hegel's overarching project
anyway so I'm not attracted to that sort
of thing Leo pawed Stan Mickey who owns
the USA I don't know that anybody owns
the let's say so I don't know I don't
know what you could possibly say
something has happened outside some sort
of loud bang we'll see what happens
after I get off of this Tommy Lynn
what's my takin objectivism if you mean
Iran's Objectivist philosophy I think
it's largely garbage you know what's the
the points in it that are actually
interesting and often right can be found
in other philosophies without all the
silly bad history of philosophy and
screeds against you know collectivism
and all that sort of stuff and without
the you know commitments to essentially
glorifying selfishness all right
let's see what else we got here so
here's a good thing isaac zurich how
important is it to teach when a
philosopher's actions contradict their
ideologies
for example conservatism certainly seems
to go against the categorical imperative
as I understand it I mean Kant's racism
is essentially in the place to go for
that is the anthropology from a
pragmatic point of view is essentially
saying that different different groups
races of human beings have different
levels of potential development right
and there's a similar problem in John
Stuart Mill by the way if you read his
on Liberty and you know utilitarianism
you get this very you know enlightened
guy if you read his remarks on
representative government you see him
saying well you know this doesn't apply
to savages by the way would it go
against the categorical imperative the
the the stance of saying we should treat
different people differently oh and what
it means is allowing them into the moral
community I think you know it would not
be so much an issue of universalization
well somebody could make a case about
that but the second formulation of
the categorical imperative you know act
always so as to treat humanity in
yourself and in others never as a mere
means but always as and yeah I think
racism would definitely go against that
I mean Connie has a lot of interesting
things you know you'd also think he'd be
against capital punishment but in the
metaphysical elements of justice he says
no categorical imperative you know can
can lead you to you know capital
punishment as a matter of fact the the
lawbreakers should realize that this is
actually a way of like preserving his
freedom and you're like come on can't so
how important is it to teach when there
are philosophers actions contradict
their ideologies I think it's quite
important I think we can point that out
and I think we can do that without like
saying well let's throw it all out burn
it down you know I think we I think what
we say is well he was really off on this
and this is this is to be attacked and
we should do two things one is we should
use the part of their own philosophy and
say you're you're not being you know
consistent here this is bad but then we
should also see if there are resources
within their philosophy that could could
address that sort of like you know when
I talk about Aristotle and his
discussions of women I think that the
Aristotelian approach applied to the
present would say bring Aristotle to the
president he would say wow I was so off
on all that like women being imperfect
men nonsense I have to revise that so
it's so good it's a good question all
right um let's see
James asked do I like neo Republican
philosophers like Quentin Skinner or
Phillip Pettit I've only read Skinner
insofar as he's talked about Hobbes I
haven't really followed him much and I
don't know Phillip Pettit so there's not
much I can say um let's see here
snoo okay asking a question that comes
up a lot in our business ethics classes
what's your opinion I'm buying
commodities produced under highly
exploitive conditions such as sweatshops
you're using unsafe
mining is it inherently immoral could it
be moral as it grows their economy so
you risking as moral immoral or like I'm
an ostrich it's better to say that the
application is immoral growing their
economy might be a nice no side effect
of it but it's it's if grooming their
economy is the goal there's probably
better ways to do it than sweatshops
right so when you have options for that
why would you select means and they're
exploitative to other people and it's
possible to say that a practice is both
it's a you wouldn't say moral and
immoral at the same time you would say
rather that there are good sides to it
and bad sides to it and in this case I
think you would say the bad sides
outweigh the good sides so you know then
question is what do we do about it
do we have options alternatives and you
know can we afford them yeah I mean this
is where those who have more resources
probably have to be held to higher
standards if we think about like
consumption of meat right going to poor
people and telling them hey you know
factory farming is terrible you
shouldn't be buying buying that meat
when it's one of the cheapest ways for
them to get what they need in their diet
that's that's not as helpful as going to
rich people and saying hey if you're
gonna eat meat ethical farming is what
you have to do you know and we could say
similar things with labor practices
right so alright Emma what do I think of
NARTH and those bombs conception of
anger well she wrote a whole book about
it right and I think that her book is
pretty good I think that she's off base
on some things that she's on point on
other things where she's on point she's
largely using other people's stuff it's
been a while since I've taken a look at
her her book so I'd have to I have to
refresh I think my main disagreements
with it were on sort of like what Howie
her can be used as
tool and I know she got the Stoics wrong
too to some degree as she usually does
so all right rain how should you
approach philosophical text what's the
best way to retain information I don't
know there is no best way and there is
no one way to approach philosophical
texts I guess the main guidelines you
could say or expect to read and reread
and reread multiple times
don't don't read them as if you're
trying to something your box or compete
with a friend or Master Pluto or
anything like prepare for a long
conversation and have the books
interrogate you you're not just you and
irrigating the books I didn't say let's
see what else we got here
all all you know it's act per all EF how
should i whistles imminent and
transcendence I'm not quite sure what
you're asking there how should I
understand it been transcendence I mean
not a big horrible person I mean I did
my master's thesis on him but that was
that was back in 97 I'm not really that
into her also I find him very boring I
would suggest you know reading down in
his stuff if you won't do it
phenomenology and the likes of coral
Heidegger etc I think phenomenology is a
good approach there's a lot of different
types of phenomenology the
phenomenologist who I'm most interested
in or mock Schaller Dietrich von
Hildebrand Bob real Marcel Martin
Heidegger you know I used to read
Levinas I'm not really that interested
in him of course you know Sartre is is
interesting as well I don't read a lot
of contemporary phenomenology but I
don't read a lot of contemporary
anything quite frankly whether it's
literature you know other their
philosophy I think it's you know it's an
interesting movement eat it chimes worth
reading too
you know and they're all doing different
things maurice merleau-ponty is another
person i should mention as well i'm
actually doing a longstanding tutorial
with a composer who wanted to work on
phenomenology as well I should mention
and and there's other there's other
authors too by the way who are doing
things similar to phenomenology just not
called phenomenology like army barracks
own and Maurice blown down you know and
some of their followers all right
Matthew Curran what do I think about the
work of john rebecca i i've only
interacted with rebecca a little bit
through stoicism today haven't read
anything other than what we've posted of
him so i can't really say much about him
logic how to read philosophy and be
critical without fear
I mean how to have courage when you read
philosophy so why would somebody have
fear when they're reading philosophy
it's kind of an interesting question
maybe some of the fears could be about
their own capacities like am I going to
be able to understand this you know
maybe I'm concerned about whether I'm up
to the task of reading philosophy and
you know you can remind yourself that
you don't have to understand a thing
that nobody does will readings sometimes
not even after many meetings you know
I'm classic text thirty years after
starting reading them we still find new
stuff in them you know next time I go
back to Plato's symposium I'm sure I'm
gonna find something I missed last time
around so maybe that's one kind of fear
and then maybe there could be fear
about people like seeing you reading
philosophy and why are you doing that
you know and there's there's other
things that we can say about that but
what other fears would a person have
maybe maybe there's a fear that like you
know you start reading stuff you're like
wow this makes a lot of sense and then
you put that book down for a while and
you go to another author and then you
have the same thing wow this makes a lot
of sense but this doesn't make the same
sense as that other one
[ __ ] is there something wrong with me
like I'm I'm you know like the person
who whoever the person they talked to
last that's the person who they believe
well okay so that could be a legitimate
fear you can be like man am I ever gonna
get to the bottom of this can I actually
attain truth and you don't have to have
like truth of the capital T for it to be
a valuable experience reading philosophy
I guess that maybe that's something that
you could say so all right I'm gonna
look through here as well a lot a lot of
questions and we got about 12 minutes
left
Eliot asked will I ever make Toulouse
videos he's very confusing
yeah he's he is very confusing he's more
confusing with guitar e if you ever
noticed that
then without guitar e he actually makes
more sense and say the logical sense
then he doesn't aunty Oedipus right or
in Si is critical and clinical all right
let me scroll back up here and then
we're probably going to be in the sort
of lightning round or I look for some
stuff I can answer really quickly
somebody keeps asking how to approach
sir and find somebody else I don't read
Sauron okay so here's a kind of
confusing one Elijah Miller do you think
Sartre equals Kierkegaard's ethical
equals I have in Karamazov equals he
ales Greek and Jewish cultists being in
time Heidegger equal Kierkegaard's
religious etc it's said I'm not going to
read through all this the equal sign is
probably a the giveaway there no these
are not equal to each other as a matter
of fact if you want to make progress in
philosophy don't try to say this is
exactly the same as this don't try to
just blend stuff together
we call that conflation you know
recognize the distinctions and
differences between things this goes all
the way back to Plato you know dialectic
is about seeing connections but also
about seeing differences between things
so that's important um Chris laingen
what do I think about Heidegger and
what's my favorite text so I think that
Heidegger is somebody who's important to
read I don't think that just because of
the Nazism we throw out everything
including being in time but I do think
that he was you know there's not just
elements within some of his stuff I mean
the black notebooks are really bad right
but there's other other things as well
where you're like well I can see how we
went the Nazi way and I think that his
treatment of his teacher whose role was
really shabby and we can go on and on
with that
but there are a lot of useful concepts
in his works so favorite work of
Heidegger I mean for me probably be I'm
right there's so much in there
I usually introduce people to Heidegger
with using the essay what is metaphysics
so I can say that at least all right we
got about 10 minutes left and so I'm
going to go through things a little bit
quicker and actually I'm going to scroll
all the way down and see if there's any
things to take from down there at this
point
all right people are arguing back and
forth guy just asked if I have a red
mocs Turner I'm not only red MOX Turner
I've actually led tutorials on him in
the past he's an interesting guy but
ultimately I think kind of a dead end
let's see here new coat EVS can I
comment on logic in particular common
practical everyday logic what's the best
text to buy Aristotelian there is no
like common everyday logic textbook I
would say usually what you're gonna find
dealing with that is like books talking
about the fallacies and they're under
the label of critical thinking you know
some of the textbooks that we typically
use in academic classes would be like
copies elements of logic or Hurley's
logic those are those are decent
textbooks that cover a lot of topics but
there's a lot of things that I always
get left out when it comes to ordinary
discussion when it comes to how we we
have philosophical logic it's almost as
if thinking like logic is its own little
area over here that has all sorts of
cool little topics but ordinary life is
a lot Messier so Zack have you ever
looked into the philosophy of human
rights if so who are some good writers
to read regarding there's a lot of good
writers to read you know I mean we teach
about human rights and ethics classes
all the time so I mean one of the things
that you do want to take a look at are
the declarations on human rights though
I would actually say those are some of
the starting points and there's quite a
few of them out there the 1949 UN you
know
Declaration of Human Rights is a good
place to start but you know the problem
with rights discourse is you got to be
able to say where rights come from and
what grounds them and what how you
measure them against each other and
that's where moral theories turn out to
be indispensable you know you can't get
away you can't get away from them
all right let's scroll up a little bit a
lot of back-and-forth here about Iran
and some stuff about rubber bullets
Winifred lay what's the relationship
between philosophy and economics I've
heard modern-day philosophers turn into
economists quite often well that would
be news to me those are two disciplines
that often don't intersect or overlap
economists can quite often be fairly
dogmatic in their assumptions about
things particularly human welfare and
rational agents and things like that I
actually did have a friend in graduate
school who started out in he was at Penn
State and he was studying economics and
he asked too many Y questions and they
said you need to go over there and
philosophy because we don't we don't
deal with that sort of stuff here when
you assume these things and so he
started he went over to philosophy and
studied with at that time big name
philosopher Stanley rose and we had kind
of like a hero complex for and Rosen is
a good philosopher and then he switched
and became a philosopher so I would say
there's not an awful lot of connection
between them you know this is sort of an
issue with many fields interdisciplinary
work a right Eliot Riker says I live in
south Minneapolis it's very crazy the
rubber bullets are meant to be shot at
the ground and then ricochet up at the
cops fire them at us directly yeah this
is
- one of the problems of the things that
are given to the cops for their policing
they're supposed to be used in a certain
way so as to minimize risk to human life
and of course because they can be used
in more aggressive ways the cops will
use them in more aggressive ways so date
Jim asks a good question is there
anything specific people can do to cause
a change in their local police system
there are a lot of things and I think we
have to do a lot of things and I think
no one single person has to try to do
them all and this is something I would I
would suggest you should google you know
huh and you could do it terms of like
how to hold the cops accountable how to
change the system there's a lot of good
pieces out there right now discussing
exactly this one of the things that you
can do is request you know information
from the police and that puts them on
notice right away that they there
there's people who are looking into
their stuff you know use Freedom of
Information acts to get a hold of arrest
records you know start writing figure
out who is on your local City Council or
whatever it happens to be start going to
council meetings start doing you know
the all these sorts of writing letters
making phone calls even to political
officials who are probably on the side
of aggressive policing call them email
them you know because sooner or later
what most politicians are pretty craven
and they can see you know which way the
wind is blowing if they get enough
people who are like listen your policies
are bad and and they don't just like hey
[ __ ] you know something like that but
you say your policies are bad really
they need to change your kind of a
putting people at risk and doing doing
the wrong thing if they get enough of
that most politicians eventually start
to like rethink their position and so
there's all sorts of things I think that
we can we can do let me see what else
we've got here
a lot of back and forth that's referring
to itself for each other there's a good
question from August I've been seeing a
lot of YouTube videos which use short
animated cartoons to explain really
complicated topics and philosophy what
if anything do you think is lost by this
sort of pop philosophy well contact with
the actual texts and the complexity of
the concepts and you know I think I
think a lot of people then also think oh
I understand the Hegelian dialectic you
know or I understand the Lakhani and
mirror theory or stage you know or
things like that and they don't they
don't know that they don't know because
they watch some you know some high-tech
some some high production but low
content video same thing goes for like
you know introductory texts and you know
there was this guy Paul Strathearn who
came out with a whole line of books like
Nietzsche in 90 minutes Descartes in 90
minutes and III was invited to review
these back as a graduate student I was
like these are garbage well of course
because it's you know it's like 50 pages
and what are you gonna actually do in 90
minutes so I think I think that's that's
the way to look at that oh here's a good
question to go out on
Lokesh gia Tola with the current unrest
how would you look at it through the
lens of the social contract so that's a
great question and as a matter of fact
my co-host on the wisdom for life show
Dan Hayes he had wanted to talk about
the social contract in the show episode
which is airing today by the way at 4:00
p.m. Central Time
where we're gonna be talking about
policing and protests and do you want to
talk about Hobbes and Locke and I was
like well I mean you can do that if you
want to but I think that you know we
could talk about a broader conception of
social contract where basically we
Accord legitimacy to the rulers and to
the you know the police and another
agencies provided certain things are
being met you know provided people's
needs
being taken care of and disputes are
being handled and all these other things
when the police part of the social
contract for America is when we're when
we don't like things we get to say
something about it
right and we get to say something about
it in ways that other people can't
easily avoid that's part of our social
contract and the cop stir often cool
with that when it's stuff like you know
white armed protesters at the Capitol
saying we don't like social distancing
and wearing masks and not being able to
go to the barber so I don't you know the
cops are cool with that right but when
you criticize the cops themselves then
suddenly it's not so cool now a little
ill use force for talking about them
using force that destroys the social
contract they don't realize this that if
they keep on pushing and pushing and
pushing like this things will get more
violent and they need to actually start
shifting and it's gonna be difficult for
many many cops and many leaders to do so
because they're so invested in you know
doing things the way that they like to
do it but if they don't social contract
is breaking and you're also seeing in
the protests people who have been on the
wrong side of the social contract for a
long time so this is actually a quite
useful concept to think about maybe
actually that's a great idea
maybe I've mentioned that I'm gonna
start doing more pop ups that are on
political issues maybe I'll talk about
the idea of social contract this month
as the thing that I'm going to use the
lens for this so it didn't get to
everybody's questions I never do looks
like people have been relatively civil
with each other which is good I had kick
out a few bad actors in here but not not
as much as in other places and I'm gonna
say goodbye to everybody got other stuff
coming up this month so we'll probably
talk about these issues some more thanks
for all of your questions and comments
and I'll see you in some of the other
online events